je pense que je pense qu'il ya des
appels du pied voilà globalement il ya
des appels du pied sur les électeurs de
gauche disant vous êtes déçu par
françois hollande
venez donc voté pour nous d'ailleurs
qu'importe venez voter pour nous à
l'élection primaire peut-être que vous
voterez pour la gauche à l'élection
présidentielle elle même parce que c'est
ça qui va se passer
moal électeurs de gauche qui décide
d'être à droite il a sa place dans la
primaire j'ai pas de problème n'est plus
à gauche il dit à boire jusqu au bilaà
zahraoui faut qu'il reste je voudrais
qu'il faut pas qu'ils viennent
l'élection de gauche n'a pas à
interférer dans la primaire de la droite
comme électeurs de droite
il n'a pas interféré dans la primaire de
la gauche parce que dans ce cas là il
faut pas faire de primaire dans ce cas
là ça veut dire qu'on est en train de
vicier la primaire est donc de vicié de
vicier les résultats de roche et
éventuellement j'ai pas dit ça et de
viande ont vu jusque là bas laissez-moi
laisse ma balle et de vicier l'élection
présidentielle elle même
donc il faut faire très attention à ça
si nous faisons il faut de la
déontologie dans l'élection primaire
c'est pas un problème la haute autorité
autorités elle fait elle si les
mécaniques